We're asked to write this right
here in word form, and
I'm not saying it out loud
because that would give the
answer away.
We have 63.15 that we want
to write in word form.
Well, the stuff to the left of
the decimal point is pretty
straightforward.
Let me actually color code it.
So we have 6, 3.
Let me do it all in
different colors.
And then we have a decimal, and
then we have a 1 and a 5.
There's one common way of doing
this, but we'll talk
about the different ways you
could express this as a word.
But we know how to write
this stuff to the left.
This is pretty straightforward.
This is just sixty-three.
Let me write that down.
So this is sixty-three.
And instead of the decimal,
we'll write, and.
Now there's two ways
to go here.
We could say, and one tenth
and five hundredths, or we
could just say, look, this
is fifteen hundredths.
One tenth is ten hundredths.
So one tenth and five hundredths
is fifteen
hundredths.
So maybe I can write it like
this: sixty-three and fifteen
hundredths.
Just like that.
Now, it might have been a little
bit more natural to
say, how come I don't say
one tenth and then five
hundredths?
And you could, but that would
just make it a little bit
harder for someone's brain to
process it when you say it.
So it could have been
sixty-three-- so let me copy
and paste that.
It could be sixty-three and, and
then you would write, one
tenth for this digit right
there, and five hundredths.
Sixty-three and one tenth and
five hundredths is hard for
most people's brains
to process.
But if you say, fifteen
hundredths, people get what
you're saying.
Not to beat a dead horse, but
this right here, this is 1/10
right here and then this
is 5/100, 5 over 100.
But if you were to add these
two, If you were to add 1/10
plus 5/100 -- so
let's do that.
If you were to add 1/10 plus
5/100, how would you do it?
You need a common denominator.
100 is divisible by both 10 and
100, so multiply both the
numerator and denominator
of this character by 10.
You get 10 on the top and
100 on the bottom.
1/10 is the same thing
as 10 over 100.
10/100 plus 5/100 is equal to
15 over 100, so this piece
right here is equal to 15/100.
And that's why we say
sixty-three and fifteen
hundredths.